.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Die Gewalt
hat Südafrika fest im Griff.
Überfälle und Morde
sind an der Tagesordnung.
Menschen werden wegen ihrer Haut-
farbe diskriminiert und attackiert.
Südafrika - Projektionsfläche
für viele Schweizer mit Fernweh.
Das war mein Bubentraum.
Eine Regenbogennation im Frieden
mit sich selbst und der Welt.
Wie würden Sie
die Stimmung heute beschreiben?
Äh ... no comment.
Der Traum, den man ...
... gelebt hat,
wurde leider vernichtet.
Diese Waffe ist geladen.
Tausende von weissen Farmern
wurden ermordet.
Es gibt keine Beweise dafür,
dass sie zu Zielen werden,
weil sie weisse Farmer sind.
Eine kleine Farm
ausserhalb von Johannesburg.
Rolf Bill
hält nur noch ein paar Schafe.
Früher war das anders.
Hier drin haben wir incubators,
mit denen wir jeweils
die Eier ausgebrütet haben.
Hier drin ist ein Futterstock.
Und hier
war der Milchtank mit der Kühlung.
Bilder aus besseren Zeiten.
Er hatte schon als Kind
von einem eigenen Bauernhof geträumt.
Vor 50 Jahren
wanderte er nach Südafrika aus
und wurde schliesslich Farmer.
Wie viele Kühe hatten Sie denn
zu den besten Zeiten?
Wir melkten zwischen 30 und 40.
Insgesamt hatten wir gegen 60.
Seine Kühe waren sein ganzer Stolz,
aber die wirtschaftliche Lage
verschlechterte sich zusehends.
Sein Betrieb hätte wachsen müssen,
um zu überleben,
aber dafür fehlte das Geld.
Also verkaufte er seine Kühe
schweren Herzens.
Nun hält er sich mit einer kleinen
AHV aus der Schweiz über Wasser.
Eigentlich wollte er einen dicken
Strich unter sein Farmerleben ziehen,
aber seine Frau
sei auf die Bremse getreten.
Heute sei er ihr dankbar dafür,
dass sie ihn vom Umzug
in eine Stadt abgehalten habe.
Eines der positiven Dinge
ist sicher das Klima.
Wir haben nicht allzu heisse Sommer,
wir haben ziemlich kalte Winter,
aber viel Sonnenschein.
Das ist ... sicher
ein grosser Pluspunkt.
Und wenn man sich so umsieht:
Es ist eine schöne area.
Wenn man lange genug hier ist,
will man eigentlich nicht mehr weg.
Eine Art südafrikanische Landi.
Der Chef ist auch Farmer.
Die beiden sind Nachbarn.
Früher war Rolf Bill hier Stammkunde.
40 kg, please.
Heute braucht er nur noch ab und zu
eine Tüte Hundefutter.
Here you go.
- (Frau) Thank you so much, Rolf.
Die Sicherheit ist ein Dauerthema.
Fast jeder ist schon
zum Opfer geworden - auch Rolf Bill.
Vor einer Weile hatten wir hier
viele Viehdiebstähle, auch bei Rolf.
Sie haben es versucht.
- Ja, sie haben es versucht.
Er hat uns alarmiert
und wir sind sofort
mit Nachtsichtgeräten gekommen.
Wir haben alle Schafe gefunden
und konnten sie ihm zurückgeben.
Er hat kein einziges verloren.
Nein. Ich bin sehr dankbar.
Die Farmer helfen sich gegenseitig -
ein Notruf genügt.
Ich schätze das sehr.
Ich bin inzwischen 73,
also kein Jungspund mehr.
Es tut gut, dass wir Nachbarn haben,
auf die wir uns verlassen können.
Sie haben sich zu einer Art
Bürgerwehr zusammengeschlossen.
Farm watch nennt sich das.
Wir machen uns Sorgen, denn die
Angriffe auf Farmen nehmen zu.
Ich weiss,
dass die Polizei versucht,
die Situation
in den Griff zu bekommen,
aber das wird nicht gelingen.
Die haben gar nicht
die Ressourcen dafür.
Darum haben sie ihre Sicherheit
selbst in die Hand genommen.
Die Beule unter dem Hemd
ist eine Pistole.
Er habe einen Waffen- und einen
Trageschein, also alles ganz legal -
und bitter nötig,
denn es werde immer ungemütlicher.
Hier sollen die Spannungen
bewusst geschürt werden.
Der weissen Minderheit,
die uns unser Land mit Gewalt
weggenommen hat, müsst ihr sagen:
"Genug ist genug. Wir nehmen die
Zukunft in unsere eigenen Hände."
Bei jedem Auftritt stimmt der
linkspopulistische Oppositionsführer
ein inzwischen verbotenes Lied an.
Wir rufen nicht dazu auf,
Weisse zu töten - noch nicht.
Ich kann
für die Zukunft nichts garantieren.
Verstehen Sie, dass die Leute,
die das hören, ausflippen werden?
Es klingt wie
ein Aufruf zum Genozid.
Heulsusen. Heulsusen.
"Ich rufe nicht dazu auf,
Weisse abzuschlachten - noch nicht."
Ich kann für die Zukunft
nichts garantieren -
v.a., wenn es so weitergeht.
- Subtext.
Wenn es so weitergeht, wird es in
diesem Land eine Revolution geben.
Das kann ich Ihnen
jetzt schon sagen.
Es wird eine
unkontrollierte Revolution geben.
Und das ist
die höchste Form der Anarchie.
Genau das
wollte Nelson Mandela verhindern.
Nach seiner Freilassung
hatte er einen grossen Traum:
Er wollte
Schwarze und Weisse versöhnen.
Nie, nie, nie wieder
soll es in diesem Land vorkommen,
dass jemand
einen anderen unterdrückt.
Die Zeit der schönen Worte
scheint vorbei zu sein.
Heute schützt sich, wer kann.
Hier haben wir
eine weitere Sicherheitsmassnahme.
In vier Zimmern
haben wir einen solchen Monitor.
Den schalten wir nachts ein,
dann dauert es einige Sekunden ...
... dann geht bald die Sirene los.
Seine Frau
löst den Bewegungsmelder aus.
* Schrille Alarmsirene *
Machen wir sie wieder aus.
Das ist genug Lärm.
Was passiert, wenn man das auslöst?
Kommt jemand? Wird jemand alarmiert?
Das ist nur für uns, nur lokal.
Sie wüssten, dass jemand im Haus ist,
und könnten die Nachbarn aufbieten.
Whisky 112 calling Whisky 3
for testing.
(Charles Waller) Whisky 3
standing by for testing, 112.
I've got
five out of five here, Charles.
I've got four out of five,
thank you very much.
Thank you, Charles. Have a good day.
Thank you very much.
Whisky 3 signing off.
Whisky 112, out.
Plaasmoorde, das bedeutet
Mord an Farmern in Afrikaans,
der Sprache der Buren.
Jedes dieser Kreuze,
die auf einem Hügel
nördlich der Hauptstadt Pretoria
aufgestellt wurden, steht für
einen ermordeten weissen Farmer.
Am Sonntag wird grilliert.
Braai nennt sich das.
Ein Stück Normalität
in immer aussergewöhnlicheren Zeiten.
Würden Sie es Schweizern noch
empfehlen, in Südafrika zu farmen?
Nein.
Entschuldigen Sie, dass es so ein
striktes Nein ist, aber: Nein.
Seine Tochter und deren Freunde
sind vorbeigekommen.
Sie mögen die Ruhe und die Landluft
am Wochenende.
Aber auf einer Farm
leben und arbeiten?
Für mich ist das vermutlich nichts.
Ich würde sowieso lieber
nach Übersee auswandern,
als in Südafrika zu bleiben.
Es ist ja völlig unklar,
wie lange Ihre Familie
noch auf dieser Farm bleiben wird.
Genau, das weiss ich.
Darum würde ich am liebsten
nach Übersee gehen,
möglichst weit weg von hier.
Sind Sie selbst denn auch bewaffnet?
Ja, bin ich.
Die Waffe ist aber im Schlafzimmer.
Wo bewahren Sie sie genau auf?
(Lachend)
In der Unterwäscheschublade.
Ist die Waffe geladen?
- Ja, ist sie.
Es ist aber keine Patrone im Lauf.
Okay. Haben Sie sie
schon mal gebraucht?
Nur übungshalber.
Und im Ernstfall würden Sie ...
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich reagieren würde.
Ich weiss es wirklich nicht.
Bilder aus der Zeit der Apartheid.
Damals galt sog. Rassentrennung,
auch am Strand.
Die Weissen unter sich,
die Schwarzen woanders.
Rassismus als Staatsform.
Dieser Rassismus wurde durch
einflussreiche Buren-Organisationen
wie die rechtsextreme
Afrikaaner Widerstandsbewegung AWB
geradezu zelebriert.
Sie waren strikt
gegen die Abschaffung der Apartheid.
Die können nicht mitbestimmen.
Die sind dazu nicht fähig.
Die haben eine andere Kultur
und Tradition als wir Weissen.
(Mann) Ihr trainiert, um zu töten.
Werdet ihr Schwarze töten?
Wenn wir angegriffen werden,
gehen wir in die Offensive.
Dann ist es natürlich erlaubt,
zu töten.
Die AWB wappnete sich
nach Mandelas Freilassung
für einen möglichen Aufstand
der Schwarzen.
Wir trainieren aus Liebe zum Volk -
um es vor dem ANC zu schützen,
der uns unser Land wegnehmen will.
Wir werden sie alle abknallen, mein
Freund, bis keiner mehr übrig ist.
Alles schien
auf einen Bürgerkrieg hinauszulaufen.
* Sprechgesang *
Hier habe ich
noch einige Bilder gefunden.
Als sich die Südafrikanerin Bessie
und der Schweizer Rolf
kennen und lieben lernten,
herrschte noch Apartheid.
Sog. Mischehen
waren gesetzlich verboten.
Wir heirateten in der St-Mary's-
Kathedrale in Johannesburg.
Hier haben wir
den Schweizer Männerchor,
der uns ein Ständchen gesungen hat.
Das klang natürlich wunderbar.
Ich musste mich offiziell
zum Farbigen erklären,
um überhaupt heiraten zu können,
weil Bessie ja aus dem Norden
der Kapprovinz stammt,
und sie ist eine Farbige, ja.
Und wie haben die Menschen
darauf reagiert?
Kein Problem.
- Kein Problem.
Während der Apartheid mussten wir
natürlich dem Gesetz gehorchen.
Nach 9 Uhr Abends durften wir
z.B. nicht mehr unterwegs sein -
also wir Schwarzen.
Aber man muss auch sagen:
Damals gab es keine Kriminalität.
Wir konnten draussen schlafen
und die Türen einfach offen lassen.
Aber ihr wart
Menschen zweiter Klasse.
Ja.
Die Apartheid steht für
die systematische Unterdrückung
der Schwarzen Bevölkerungsmehrheit
durch die weisse Minderheit.
Der Widerstand wuchs stetig, wurde
aber lange brutal niedergeschlagen.
Nelson Mandela suchte
nach der Apartheid die Versöhnung.
Eine der zentralen Fragen war eine
gerechtere Verteilung des Landes.
Mandela hoffte, dieses Problem
würde sich von allein lösen.
Dem war allerdings nicht so.
Man kann von der Erbsünde
dieses Landes sprechen.
Den ursprünglichen Bewohnern
Südafrikas ihr Land wegzunehmen,
das war die Erbsünde.
Weisse kontrollieren immer noch 70 %
der landwirtschaftlichen Flächen.
Ein Reiz- und Wahlkampfthema.
In unserem Manifest legen wir dar,
wie wir eine Landreform
beschleunigen wollen.
Dazu gehören auch
Enteignungen ohne Entschädigung.
Auch Rolf Bills Familie
könnte schon bald enteignet werden.
Beschäftigt es Sie, dass man Ihnen
die Farm wegnehmen könnte?
Ja, natürlich beschäftigt mich das.
Wir haben für diese Farm
so hart gearbeitet.
Die können doch nicht einfach kommen
und sie uns wegnehmen.
Vielleicht können sie.
Robert Mugabe hat es
im Nachbarland Simbabwe vorgemacht.
Anfang der 2000er-Jahre
befahl auch er eine sog. Landreform.
D.h. konkret:
Weisse Farmer wurden systematisch
enteignet und vertrieben.
Sie riefen uns an und sagten nur:
"Ihr habt zwei Tage,
um von der Farm zu verschwinden."
Wer konnte, floh.
Viele andere wurden umgebracht.
Die einstige Kornkammer Afrikas
wurde binnen kürzester Zeit
zu einem Armenhaus,
gezeichnet von Hungersnöten
und Unterernährung,
nur durch Hilfslieferungen
aus dem Ausland am Leben erhalten.
Rolf Bill hofft,
dass Südafrika dieses sog.
Simbabwe-Szenario erspart bleibt.
Im Interesse des Landes -
und natürlich auch in seinem eigenen.
Es sieht momentan nicht so gut aus.
Im Moment
können wir noch Minze verkaufen.
Pfefferminze.
Heute könnte er keinem mehr raten,
nach Südafrika auszuwandern.
Zu seiner Zeit sei es allerdings noch
ein Land der Chancen gewesen.
Ich wollte eigentlich aus Neugier
nach der Lehre irgendwo hingehen.
Damals konnte man auch nach Kanada,
Australien oder Neuseeland gehen.
Südafrika war ...
... eigentlich das Land,
das mir am besten gefiel.
Sie suchten auch ...
... Berufsleute, die ...
Ich hatte in der Schweiz
Spengler und Installateur gelernt.
Solche Leute suchten die damals.
Sie zahlten den Flug
und zahlten für die Unterkunft,
bis man Arbeit fand.
Ich wollte vielleicht
ein oder zwei Jahre bleiben,
und jetzt bin ich halt
seit 50 Jahren hier.
War man damals als Weisser
noch herzlich willkommen?
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Richtig.
Wie würden Sie
die Stimmung heute beschreiben?
Äh ... no comment.
Gab es nie Momente im Leben,
in denen Sie
in die Schweiz zurückkehren wollten?
Sicher ab und zu, ja.
Aber heute eher nicht.
Meine Wurzeln hier
sind ziemlich tief,
obwohl ich noch
durch und durch Schweizer bin.
Wann waren Sie
zuletzt in der Schweiz?
1997.
Vor 23 Jahren?
- Ja.
Das ist ja ewig her.
- Ich hatte ... keine Zeit mehr.
(Lachend) Keine Zeit?
Ja.
My goodness, look at it.
Das habe ich mal
im Toggenburg gekauft.
Diese Glocke
haben wir bei Viehschauen
immer einer schönen Kuh angezogen.
* Langgezogener Jodelgesang *
This is how a Zäuerli sounds.
Welche Gefühle haben Sie,
wenn Sie das hören?
Wunderbar.
- Wunderbar.
Sie sind ein richtiger
Heimwehschweizer.
Ja, so ist es.
Ja, ja.
* Weiterer Jodelgesang *
Soweto: Township-Siedlungen
im Südwesten von Johannesburg.
Hier mögen sie nicht mehr
auf eine gerechtere Verteilung
des Landes warten.
Hier nehmen sie sich Land
und bauen darauf.
Diese Siedlung heisst Protea Glen
und hat inzwischen
sogar einen Gemeindeleiter,
der selbstbewusste Forderungen
an den südafrikanischen Staat hat.
Die Regierung muss uns helfen
und diese Strasse instand setzen.
Die Regierung wird sagen,
dass ihr auf besetztem Land lebt.
Ja, aber inzwischen
sind wir hier zu Hause.
Und wir bleiben ja hier und besetzen
nicht einfach weiteres Land -
ausser man würde es uns anbieten.
Hier wohne ich.
- Seit wann?
Seit 2015.
Stand dieses Haus damals schon?
Nein, ich habe es gekauft.
- Von wem?
Es war so: Ich habe mir dieses Land
genommen und ein Haus draufgestellt.
Sie haben sich das Land
einfach genommen?
Ja,
ich habe es mir einfach genommen.
Und wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Ich fühle mich toll.
Wenn ich mir dieses Land
nicht genommen hätte,
hätte ich jetzt kein Zuhause.
Ich bin stolz auf das,
was ich getan habe.
Ich weiss, es ist falsch,
aber es ist jetzt mein Zuhause.
Sie sagen, es sei falsch. Was genau?
Der Besitzer des Landes
würde wohl sagen:
"Das ist meins.
M i r  geht es schlecht."
Aber ich habe keine Wahl.
Ich brauche ein Zuhause.
Das ist meine Küche.
Hier essen wir.
Und das ist mein Schlafzimmer.
Hier schlafe ich.
Und hier schlafen meine Kinder.
Wer kein Land hat,
muss es sich nehmen.
So sehen es inzwischen viele.
Wir werden kämpfen.
Das ist unser Land.
Wir werden bleiben.
Wir gehen nirgendwohin.
* Drängende Musik *
Er ist vor vier Jahren von Südafrika
in die Schweiz umgezogen.
Peter Bernhard und seine Frau Carmen
würden allerdings
auch gerne wieder zurückgehen.
Selbstverständlich
würden wir sofort nach Hause gehen.
Carmen ist von dort,
ich war 36 Jahre permanent dort -
40 Jahre mit der Zeit,
in der wir hier sind.
Wir haben immer noch Sachen dort.
Es ist keine Option.
Wir würden sofort zurückgehen.
Aber es müsste Normalität herrschen.
Bis es so weit ist, führen sie
ein Restaurant im Kanton Aargau.
Er hat seine berufliche Karriere
in der Gastronomie
in der Schweiz angefangen,
wurde dann in Südafrika Grossfarmer,
ist nun zurück in der Schweiz
und richtet wieder Salate an.
Kann ich dir helfen?
- Danke, Schatz, im Moment nicht.
Jetzt machen wir schönes
geschnetzeltes Kalbfleisch.
Ich kann kein Familienmitglied
an die Kriminalität verlieren.
Dort unten herrscht Brutalität.
Es ist ja nicht so ...
... dass es
harmlose Kriminalität ist,
dass sie einem nur etwas wegnehmen,
sondern für sie ist ein Lebewesen
im Moment nichts wert.
Das will ich meiner Familie ...
... nicht antun.
Er ging mit leeren Taschen
nach Südafrika, arbeitete hart
und investierte schlau.
Das ist jetzt eben fast Nostalgie.
Da kommen uns
schon fast wieder Tränen.
Die Bernhards erlebten hautnah,
wie die Gewalt in ihrem kleinen
Paradies zu eskalieren begann.
Wir haben einen Traum gelebt.
Und dieser Traum ...
... den wir gelebt haben,
wurde leider vernichtet.
Tausende weisse Farmer
wurden ermordet.
Ich sage nicht,
es waren nur weisse Farmer,
aber sehr, sehr viele weisse Farmer.
In den ländlichen Gebieten
werden die weissen Farmer
effektiv dezimiert.
Einen Teil seines Landes
verpachtet er nun,
den Rest managt ein Angestellter.
Für seine Familie hat er
nur noch eine Möglichkeit gesehen:
aus Südafrika zu fliehen.
Wir haben Alarmanlagen,
wir haben Lichter, wir haben Hunde.
Die Hunde
werden ab und zu vergiftet.
Es gibt keine Nacht, in der man
effektiv ruhig durchschlafen kann.
In vielen Nächten
stand ich drei-, vier-, fünfmal auf,
weil ein Hund anschlug - das muss
kein Einbrecher gewesen sein,
das kann auch eine Schlange oder
sonst ein Wildtier gewesen sein.
Aber wenn die Alarmlichter
ums Haus angingen,
holte ich halt
die 9 mm unter dem Kissen hervor.
Ich hatte eine Schrotflinte
unter dem Bett.
So lebten wir.
Und so leben immer mehr Südafrikaner,
stellt das Institut für
Sicherheitsstudien in Pretoria fest.
Es sei nicht nur ein Gefühl,
es werde tatsächlich immer schlimmer,
sagt Gareth Newham.
Die Kriminalitätsraten steigen -
und sind erklärbar.
Die Fähigkeit des Staates,
die organisierte Kriminalität
zu bekämpfen,
ist weitgehend verschwunden.
Das ist ein Erbe
der von Korruption gezeichneten Ära
unseres Ex-Präsidenten Jacob Zuma.
Er hat viele fähige Leute entlassen
und seine Günstlinge eingesetzt,
auch bei der Polizei und der Justiz.
Die waren inkompetent,
also stieg die Kriminalität an.
Aber auch, weil sich
die Wirtschaft abgekühlt hat.
Mehr Arbeitslosigkeit,
Ungleichheit und Armut
führen zu mehr Kriminalität.
Ortstermin an einem Tatort.
Sandra van Zyl
betreibt eine Eierfarm
und ist kürzlich
brutal überfallen worden.
Als ich diese Tür öffnete,
standen plötzlich sechs bewaffnete
Schwarze mit Sturmhauben vor mir.
Ich versuchte,
die Tür zu schliessen,
aber sie fingen sofort an,
mich ins Gesicht zu boxen.
Sie schlugen mir die ganze Zeit mit
den Waffen auf den Kopf und schrien:
"Wo ist das Geld, Schlampe?"
Sie zwangen mich,
mich nackt auszuziehen.
Sie sagten mir,
sie würden mich vergewaltigen.
Sie rissen mir alle Kleider vom Leib
und wollten,
dass ich mich dort drüben hinsetze.
Plötzlich kam einer
mit kochendem Wasser.
Sie fingen an, mir das kochende
Wasser ins Ohr zu giessen.
Das war ein grauenvoller Schmerz.
Ein bekanntes Muster.
Unbekannte, hier gefilmt
von einer Überwachungskamera,
dringen irgendwo ein,
um ihre Opfer nicht nur zu berauben,
sondern auch stundelang zu foltern.
Diese Gewalt
ist meist gut erklärbar.
Einerseits
wollen sie damit herausfinden,
wo die Opfer alle möglichen
Wertsachen versteckt haben,
andererseits kann es aber auch
um Machtfragen
innerhalb der Gang gehen.
Die Opfer werden gequält,
um der eigenen Gang zu sagen:
"Wenn ihr nicht auf mich hört,
mache ich das auch mit euch."
Es gibt also oft Gründe
für die scheinbar sinnlose Gewalt.
Opfer wie Sandra van Zyl würden nicht
aufgrund ihrer Hautfarbe ausgewählt.
Kriminelle hätten nur ein Interesse:
Beute machen ―
möglichst viel, möglichst schnell.
Es geht den Tätern ausschliesslich
um den Zugang zu Wertsachen.
Die meisten Opfer sind nicht Weisse,
sondern Schwarze aus der
Mittelklasse, die in Städten wohnen.
Die haben iPads,
Mobiltelefone und Schmuck.
Klar, weisse Farmer scheinen Geld
zu haben und werden darum zu Zielen,
aber es gibt keine Beweise dafür,
dass sie zu Zielen werden,
weil sie weiss sind
oder weil sie Farmer sind.
Ich denke definitiv,
dass sie gezielt Weisse aussuchen.
Ganz sicher.
Sie haben mich ja die ganze Zeit
"weisse Schlampe" genannt.
Schon ihre Sprache
war voller Hass gegen Weisse.
Eine grosse Versöhnung - mit diesem
Traum fing das moderne Südafrika an.
Wir schliessen einen Bund,
in dem alle Südafrikaner,
Schwarze und Weisse,
keine Angst mehr haben müssen.
Sie sollen wissen,
dass wir ihnen ihre Menschenwürde
garantieren werden.
Eine Regenbogennation, im Frieden
mit sich selbst und der Welt.
Was für ein Witz,
Nelson Mandelas Traum.
Er glaubte
als junger Mann tatsächlich,
dass wir hier alle
friedlich zusammenleben würden.
Wenn er gewusst hätte,
was alles noch kommen würde,
wäre er sicher sehr enttäuscht
von seinem Volk.
Schrecklich enttäuscht.
Zurück in der Schweiz
bei Peter Bernhard,
seiner Frau und deren Tochter.
Sie führten ein glückliches Leben
in Südafrika,
bis die Ehefrau
eines Abends nicht nach Hause kam.
Sie war entführt worden und tauchte
erst am nächsten Morgen wieder auf.
Ihr Mann fand sie schliesslich -
nachhaltig traumatisiert
vom Erlebten.
Ich ging so schnell wie möglich
ins Privatspital in Krugersdorp.
Sie wurde untersucht.
Gott sei Dank
hatten wir alles richtig gemacht.
Meine Frau
ist heute gesund, aber ...
... sie hat auch
Schaden davongetragen.
Das war für die Familie
eine schlimme Sache.
Das möchten wir nicht mehr erleben.
Das war ein major factor
in der Entscheidung,
dieses Paradies
hinter uns zu lassen.
Denn ein Kind und eine Frau
zu ersetzen, ist nicht möglich.
Alles andere kann man ersetzen.
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Vielen anderen in Südafrika
geht es genauso.
Wir waren in der Lage, zu gehen.
Sehr viele andere wollen gehen,
können aber nicht,
weil sie genau wissen, dass sie hier
auf dem Sozialamt landen.
weil sie keine Rücklagen haben.
Sie wollen nicht weg
und sie können auch nicht,
aber vielleicht
müssen sie schon bald.
Wie wäre es für Sie, wenn Sie die
Farm irgendwann verlassen müssten,
weil Sie z.B. enteignet werden?
- Das wäre tragisch.
Da gibt es nur ein Wort: tragisch.
Ich wehre mich dagegen auch,
so gut ich kann.
Denn, ja ...
Wir haben das so aufgebaut.
Wir sind hier glücklich.
Wenn da einer käme und sagen würde:
"Ich nehme dir das jetzt weg",
würde ich mich wehren.
* Langsamer Jodelgesang *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020